hey man this is big for me not only
because I you know this guy when he won
his SCI Young Award and was playing in
the postseason goes so way back I was
covering him on SportsCenter that's
number one but number two this is Big
Daddy points for me and I never thought
I would ever say that but I also never
thought I would ever introduce Barry
Zito as the unmasked Rhino but these are
all true facts because my kids cannot
get enough of the masked singer and and
we're excited to see Barry Zito unmasked
last night because they've been
wondering who that damn Rhino is and he
joins us right here now live on the Rich
Eisen show the 2002 sy Young Award
winner and the 2012 World Series champ
with the San Francisco Giants how are
you Barry Zito I'm doing a kids love the
feel right for the kids are you kidding
me it's a Wednesday night fixture in my
household Barry oh dude it's such a
great concept and I mean the mat does
the costumes are just incredible I know
so how did you get hooked up with with
this Barry
yeah they reached out to us and just
saying hey you know would you want to be
interested you know and i kind of
obviously i'd seen this show but I
started digging a little deeper in the
research I was like man there's a lot of
you know legit
you know performers people that have
been singing and dancing their whole
lives and so I was a little intimidated
at first but my wife was like you got to
do this it's a once-in-a-lifetime
experience you're probably gonna learn a
lot even though you're scared that I'm
doing all that and right now you know I
jumped and almost I was surprised that I
made it as far as I did I mean there are
some incredible people they got voted
off you know yeah I mean for sure did
you choose the Rhino outfit how does
that work did you personally choose that
one yeah they give you options you know
they gave me some options and as you
know I you know I was always kind of a
little more maybe like a sensitive kind
of different artistic guy and baseball
and so it's funny I had I never truly
embraced you know who I was you know
being raised by musicians and all that
until later in life and so the Rhino for
me really represented that big strong
intimidating guy that I always tried to
be on the field but you know in reality
that's not totally who I am and so I got
to kind of mix that with my more you
know artistic side on stage of the mass
so it was a perfect balance yeah so it's
so it was not based on your kids how
many kids do you have Barry I have three
yeah because that was route that was
revealed last night I guess when you
were taping this back that you had just
had a newborn so did the kids was this
based on on dad doing it because the
kids watch the show or that was part of
it this was me just you know I mean
musics been my passion even tried before
baseball but you know for me it was just
an opportunity to do something in music
that was way out of my comfort zone and
you know just to push myself into more
and more discomfort you know with me
you know whenever whenever I'm scared or
afraid of something I have to do it
because I usually learn and and you know
grow as a person more than I ever would
when I feel comfortable and secure you
know I was about to say uncomfortable
were you referring to the costume I
cannot imagine wearing a rhinoceros
costume for as long as you did Barry
yeah it's pretty
it was discombobulating being in that
costume especially the first few weeks
where you put this thing on they don't
really give you a lot of rehearsal
rehearsal time and you're on stage you
know you're singing you're having a do
choreography you're having to hit
certain marks on the stage where the
cameras and the lighting are waiting for
you and then you have to sing well you
know and you're singing live so I mean
there's a lot of verticals going on for
the brain at that point so it was kind
of an overload but after a few weeks I
really started to get this sixth sense
of where I was in space even though I
couldn't really see out of that thing so
there's no second tanks that's that's
you know so it's live on tape you get
one shot at it that's it and that's yeah
yeah live studio audience you know
you're singing too legit in the mic you
know some people have microphones built
into their mask but you know you're
legitimately singing in that moment and
so you screw up it's not gonna be pretty
Barry Zito here on the Rich Eisen show
and now again you've said that you're a
music guy maybe even before a pitcher
and you did have an EP that you put out
called no secrets in 2017 and your
Twitter in Instagram feeds are at Barry
Zito music all that's
you know ken Jeong nailed it last night
so did Jenny McCarthy and we'll get into
that in a second but Robin Thicke who is
a legit like singer thought you were
Trace Adkins and Nicole Scherzinger
who's a legit performer thought you were
Jason Aldean now Barry that is those are
some serious music names they thought
you were yeah now that was super I mean
super flattering night it's you know to
get I think someone even through our
Lionel Richie at one point I was like oh
come on like that's amazing right so I'm
inside dem Rhino masochists pumping you
know while they're doing that but yeah I
mean I was really I was glad that I kind
of threw him off the trail for a while I
think at one point Jenny kind of stood
up and she had it all figured out which
was shocking to me you know I guess and
I think Jenny's like a huge baseball fan
too and and she follows the game pretty
close and you know but but I was pretty
excited to have these these country you
know singer names thrown at me at least
you know that meant I was doing
something right I guess it's a good it
was really great and my kids loved it
and it was a lot of fun watching on
Wednesday night I got Barry Zito the
recently unmasked singer on the masked
singer made it all the way to the
semifinals last night currently now here
on the Rich Eisen show let's talk a
little bit about so who did you hear did
you hear from any of your old teammates
once you've got unmasked on the last one
yeah who was it the first one that
texted me I think was Matt Cain who I
pitched with with the Giants yes um so
Matt was like he's like dude he's like
come on he's like it's just are you the
Rhino
you know and I was like nah man that's
crazy someone else just said that what
what is that show anyways I've never
I've never seen that guy it's good you
know I'm trying to play dumb and don't
want to get in trouble with attorneys
they keep it on lockdown over there at
the mess singer so oh I know like we
couldn't promote you for the last three
days and I actually you know my kids
think the world of that show as I
mentioned I actually tried to snake some
cash off my child my 11 year old last
night who tried to take some money off
me if you were really Jim
Jason Aldean underneath and I'm like
well if Ken Jong's right do I get the
$10 you want I actually use that last
night very you know a shame I'm not
ashamed I love that you got it yeah you
gotta leverage that okay good so we're
both fathers of the year right here on
the Richardson show let's go down a
little bit of so-and-so Bruce Bochy
didn't reach out to you say uh that
that's you as the Rhino it's basically
you know boats didn't you know boats
actually just text me today though and
it's always great hearing from boats man
he text me he just said hey man so you
did get you know I got to do my booking
for her murder he did great on the game
and great job Z so he's watching the
masked singer so you're severely Bruce
Bochy is a mass finger guy that reeks of
grandchildren Barry that's what that's
smooth that's what that reeks up to me
grant you really does you're right you
know for sure so let's go down memory
lane a little bit here Barry
the the best game you ever pitched would
be what it's the best game you ever
pitched Oh hands down 2012 NLCS Game
five in st. Louis elimination game but I
think just six years of poor performance
with the Giants after a huge contract
and able to come through and kind of
help save the you know the series and
then get back to the World Series there
were one but that game for sure was
luckier game for me why is that other
than just obviously the stakes but why
why would that be
I just really tried to validate you know
I tried to prove that I was worth the
money first a lot of years you know and
I went through a lot of spiritual
battles and spiritual journeys you know
and and I recently just kind of finished
this in a book so it's fresh in my head
but I you know for me it was like I
signed this contract I tried to over
perform you know throw a shutout every
game and so finally by that point of six
years you know I I finally realized like
man just just be who you are even if
it's 85 and you know and a curveball and
a changeup just do that and see what
happens instead of psyching yourself out
so I was able to do that and you know
even lay down a bunt and got a ribby I
mean it was a magical game for me but um
you know it just it just helped kind of
deliver what I always wanted to deliver
to the fans of San Francisco for
bringing me over there you know which
was help elbows to help win a World
Series you know it's amazing to hear to
bear it because what's the mental aspect
of pitching I mean really you're where
clearly you've mentioned a couple times
about you know about what goes on
between your temples and how much that
must be so difficult and but it just
looked so many times that you were in
such great command certainly in that
postseason one six ninety RA in that
postseason I remember obviously the da's
Yankees games that used to be must-see
television back in the early that's when
you were saying or whatever what is it
about the mental aspect of this game
that's that's so difficult yeah I mean I
think you know it's a team sport but in
a lot of ways it's an individual sport
you know because it's pitcher verse
daughter um you know it's it's almost
like a tennis match I mean you're just
staring down you know 60 80 feet away
and you're you're staring at your
opponent and so you know I think it's
like a lot of things in life but it's
which is you know do I trust myself or
not and so you know pitching is I trust
you know I may not trust that I can
strike this guy out because I can't
guarantee that I can't control that but
if I try to dominate the things I can
control which is you know time up my
delivery and release this pitch you know
and commit to the pitch a hundred
percent then that's good enough for me
and so I always had my biggest success
when I could say you know I might get my
butt kicked today but at least I'm gonna
you know promise that I'm gonna do my
best on every single pitch and and that
is something I can control and so when I
could get into that headspace man the
results were always pretty darn good but
when I was trying to prove to the world
that I could you know win a game or
strike this guy out or you know be the
man oh did not go well Barry Zito here
on the Rich Eisen show and again I know
you're out of the game but I don't know
how much you're into what what is going
on in the game right now and some
comments that were made by a fellow
Scion Ward winner Blake Snell just last
night on his twitch feed about wanting
to be paid every dime that he
should be paid because of kovat 19 about
playing again Barry I know that you we
got John to talk about masked singer and
some other things during memory lane but
I'm wondering what your thoughts are
about a player saying that he wants to
be fully paid in full to run the risk of
playing baseball this year yeah I mean
that's that's I'm not totally schooled
but I mean just getting some info from
you he right now it's a real tricky
situation right we know what we don't
want to put anyone else at risk and you
know I will say that everyone is making
sacrifices right now and and you know
there's a lot of people that are in
precarious situations and sacrificing
their family and children that are a lot
less stable financially you know then
possibly major league players so I just
I just feel like we have to see this
thing with a with the perspective and
really get outside of ourselves you know
and just be totally honest about how
good or you know good or bad we actually
do have it and obviously again you're
somebody with how old are your three
kids right now Barry held up 5-2 and
about three months yeah I mean you're in
it so I mean if this was your situation
when you were playing it would be
difficult for you to quarantine I
imagine right yeah
no I mean it would I mean you know
people have families and children at
home it's just that balance of you know
we got the economy and in kind of the
life that we're all trying to get back
to and then we have you know the health
scare it's it's incredibly difficult on
all sides I mean the the American
government as well I mean you know
they're just second-guessed on every
step they do it's it's not easy for
anybody right now Barry's you know here
on the Rich Eisen show a few more
minutes left with you okay so let me
let's go down a little bit more memory
lane the the one batter that you faced
where you're like okay I think I got
this guy who was the one guy who were
most confident against your money you
know I mean I would say cuz me and a-rod
really squared up a lot early in my
career he was in Texas I was in Oakland
and for whatever reason I had I had good
success against Alex you know and then
you know when he went over to New York
he got me a couple times I remember he
had a grand slam off me I think it was
opening day in Oakland
Oh five or six but he got me on that
grand slam and I remember he hit that
and he kind of looked at me because we
were friends and he was like yeah he's
like been waiting for that one for a
minute so but uh yeah you know it's
funny like that in the game you have
success against some guys and and other
guys just completely take you you know
take you deeper the other about me I was
like Jerry Hairston yeah I was a great
hold that would be my question - so
Jerry Hairston was a guy that just you
just couldn't get out that's who it was
and Jerry Hairston just owned me
gosh he owned me and then yeah well I
would say any backup catcher that was
like getting their first start in ten
days
that guy was guaranteed to hit a home
run off me it was just I don't know what
it was about backup catchers but they
would always just take me deep but my my
EP just got in my ear down bouys you
mentioned the word Placido Polanco also
Placido Polanco dude come on that guy I
mean he was legit though that guy could
find the barrel no matter what fastball
off skis off the plate in out up down I
mean he was incredible so ya know he was
one of my nemesis for for sure alright
last one for you Barry was Jeremy Giambi
safe oh wow
I think he was safe nice to do I really
do and I you know I know a lot of people
are upset that Jeremy didn't slide in
that 2001 what was the ALDS yep the flip
player was Mike Mussina got a one
nothing lead cuz one of the few mistakes
I guess you made or was that was that a
good pitch that that that Posada took
you deep onto for the only Roddick Andy
what it was like it was like three feet
over the wall I mean literally just
three feet but no I mean there was a lot
of controversy riding Jeremy slide but
at the end of the day dude Jeremy came
around third probably looked saw Shane
Spencer throw the ball in from right
field no saw that the ball is going to
go over the cutoff you know over the
cutoff man's head but and the last thing
I ever expected is this the friggin
shortstop was going to be over there on
the first base line so I actually I
think most guys would have done the
exact same
because Derek Jeter should have never
been on the first-base line never I mean
like it and and then he flips it and so
you think again Jeremy got in his foot
down before the the tag was applied I do
yep and where were you I mean I'm
talking millimeters you know what I mean
but when I do you had a good look to
right from the dugout you got a good
look yeah I mean you know there's a lot
of foul territory in Oakland so we're
pretty far so I don't I don't know if
you can trust my opinion but you know
and maybe I'm a little biased I
understand that I understand that I
completely would understand that but
there is a lot of you're right
you could fit you could fit like a par 3
golf hole on the foul territory oh yeah
no that place is a pitchers dream in oh
yeah well hey look Barry congrats on
getting as far as you did and the masked
singer it'll be something you know for
you to show all your kids four years
from now man what a blast what a blast
thanks for coming on and sharing the
time absolutely thanks so much rich you
got it that's Barry Zito the Rhino hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here